hi i'm the chad tom green and now it's
time for roll call
something you might recall is i played
the chad in charlie's angels the chad hi
i'm the chad i'm the chad it's of course
in the first charlie's angels where i
meet drew starfish in the tugboat it was
actually where i met drew i was when i
was in the movie charlie's angels when
she asked me to be in the movie and
became friends one of the reasons that
you know we got to know each other in
the first place was i admired your work
so much
and so i reached out to you and you know
asked you to come and do charlie's
angels and you so graciously said yes
i just i that was so exciting getting to
do that movie with with you and uh you
know we kind of uh
sort of hit it off
right away pretty much it was not in the
script that i was supposed to fall off
the boat but i remember i suggested it
to the director mick g and in the scene
drew is walking up the side of the
of the boat saying you know the chad was
great right and i'm eating eggs on the
end of this boat i whispered to mcgee
the director hey you know i think it'd
be kind of funny if i fell into the
water after he said well you know i
don't think we can do that we don't have
a stunt person here to coordinate that
so i didn't do it and then after we shot
the take mcgee i thought about it he
came back up to me whispered me up in my
ear he said you know what i thought
about it let's do one more take and fall
off the boat this time so uh we did one
more take drew did not know i was gonna
fall off and i did that and it kind of
was kind of a
big deal people were pretty you know
like uh sort of surprised let's say on
the set that i did that i remember got a
big laugh from drew and i felt pretty
good about that it's always fun doing
something unexpected when i tour doing
stand-up comedy anybody named chad in
the world now will come up to me after
the show and say you
really messed up my life man because uh
if you're and if your name is chad you
know this because now people will walk
up to people named chad and they'll say
are you the chad are you the chad so
it's a it's a lot of fun anytime i meet
a chad they always bring that up i'm the
chat yeah
i'm the child you are the champion
i'm the triad
it might be the chat
good morning starfish good morning the
chad
[Music]
you